out in wisconsin we're seeing the
devastating and deadly consequences of
the extreme left's anti-law enforcement
pro-criminal agenda there's no other way
to say it
make no mistake the parade attack in
wisconsin is the direct result of weak
veil policies that allow violent
criminals out on the street with no
consequences and no accountability
and tonight we're learning even more
about milwaukee's far left district
attorney
john chisholm
and his office's efforts to set
astronomically low bail for some of the
most violent actors
because the suspect in the waukesha
wisconsin parade massacre daryl brooks
jr he's a career criminal who had an
active warrant for skipping bail on a
sex crime charge in nevada and was
released on just one thousand dollars
bail in wisconsin after being arrested
for allegedly punching the mother of his
child one of
many charges on his rap sheet
but that didn't stop far-left
prosecutors from letting him back out on
the street where just days later he
mowed down dozens at a christmas parade
killing six including young children
according to authorities
and the deaths now include
eight-year-old jackson sparks who
underwent brain surgery but died from
his injuries yesterday
we continue to pray for the victims and
their families seemingly senseless
but get this
despite the undeniable failures of these
far-left bail policies the extreme
socialists left
yep they're doubling down
just listen to a self-described blm
militant in milwaukee claiming that the
attack
it's actually the sign of a revolution
to come
watch
we may have to wait and see what they
say about why this happened
but it's
not possible
that the revolution has started
in wisconsin
starting with this christmas parade
initial person who reached out to me
said that they believe that this
has to do with the verdict
wrong about literally everything he just
said
but what exactly did he mean by that
what kind of revolution is he calling
for he hasn't clarified that statement
after being asked by the fox news
channel but it's not difficult to infer
blm national leadership has made their
affinity for marxism very clear
any so-called revolution that starts
with mowing down innocent and
defenseless kids and elderly people at a
christmas parade
is sheer evil
but even in the aftermath of this
tragedy the white house is refusing to
back down from their destructive and
dangerous push to end cash bail with one
white house official telling fox news
and i quote
ending cash bail will not automatically
put people charged with crimes on the
streets
oh
thank you very much for that poignant
clarification just the latest word salad
deception from the biden harris team
and don't forget
it was harris herself who in 2020
promoted a fund to bail out violent
rioters
in minneapolis while buildings were
still smoldering
so tonight ask yourself is there any
policy sincere question any policy being
pushed by the far left that actually
improves the lives of middle and working
class americans
can you name a single one
literally just one
abolish police abolish prisons open
borders and cash bail who is this
helping
other than brazen criminals
and of course their unquestioning allies
in the media continue to enable and
amplify this reckless radicalism
for example
just look at this tweet from the new
york times consider the source quote the
grief in waukesha wisconsin had been
concentrated on the loss of five adults
after an suv barreled through a
christmas parade on sunday
but the close-knit milwaukee suburb is
also reeling from the toll on children
end quote
so i guess according to the times that
suv just drove itself
but the media malpractice
it doesn't stop there just imagine if it
was the other way around
because after a wave of shoplifting by
brazen criminals out in northern
california
members of the media so-called
they don't even want us to use the term
looting anymore
just look at this headline from an abc7
article in the bay area quote
experts always the experts experts
caution use of looting in quotes in
describing rash of bay area smash and
grabs
don't believe you're lying eyes it's
it's mostly peaceful shoplifting after
all
don't forget this is all the natural
consequence of the left's normalization
of criminality and property damage
what's next calling statue destruction
community revitalization
but of course former president trump he
warned us this would happen
removing statues of thomas jefferson
happened just right here in just in new
york city just this week
and other statues all across america he
said it wouldn't stop
with confederate statues it would go all
the way to our founders he's right
this is all fruit of the same poisonous
tree and part of a larger plan to
destroy america as we know it to tear
down our most sacred institutions to
tear down america's sense of patriotism
to tear down our sense of sovereignty
and to tear down the values that make
this country the greatest in the world
values like freedom of speech the free
enterprise system
and basic law and order
their ultimate goal
to destroy and demoralize everyday
americans and to try to force compliance
with an agenda hell-bent on turning
their far left fantasies into reality
but we have some good news as well
common sense americans all across
america are standing up i meet them
on many mornings on fox and friends
they're standing up for patriotism
they're standing up for prosperity
they're standing up for property and
they're standing up for the vision of
our founding fathers hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else